I hope I can get away with this it's a
beauty
so how's the wife he said oh she's dead
this is Dad do the game
I'll show you if you want
to show me so are we up to his
tournament building through the close
that's the entrance to the tournament
sure enough there's a big Moon to Earth
it was a bums techno
he says is that her it's his day he says
would you leave a bum stuck in her foot
he says I need somewhere to park my bike
[Applause]
um the importance of women in comedy
what was it they're not the other states
cannot be overstated
so let's take a look oh sorry that's
still your bit Chris sorry
serious yes let's take a look it's my
line
I think you know a girl is too young for
you if you're having to make the
airplane noise to get your in her
mouth
here comes the train into the tunnel
they photographed every Road in the
whole world and they put them on Google
Earth on the computer and you can go
there and you sit in front of the
computer you think I can go anywhere
anywhere in the world where should I go
the same conclusion my house first you
don't land exactly on your house you're
sort of where is it there it is that's
our house on Google Earth darling come
and look leave the kids they find in the
bath come and look
it's our car
my favorite time of the year is when I
just get to go skiing and you haven't
got to do your hair and makeup you
haven't got to have all that awkwardness
just put your helmet on put your snood
on no makeup it's great and actually
I've brought my skiing stuff
I'm pretty sure I would recognize you in
skiing gear so I've got um a beard
and a viking horns
and um this is kind of my look so much
more comfortable and it's warm
and um you just don't have to have that
awkward social is that you is it not
how's how's Jimmy that kind of thing
that's a challenging wank
can you have a context-free work if
Ricky Gervais shouts Mong in a forest
over and over again
and there's no Americans there to tell
him he's a genius
unlikely chat up lines your father must
have been a thief and I'm gonna catch
him if it's the last thing I do your
father
[Laughter]
if you sort of think a letter is
arbitrary a word okay it's a thing you
know whatever you know floor can't think
of any others and it's supposedly made
up of lettuce but it's not made up of
letters it's made up of lines some of
them are curly some of them join up some
of them cross each other it's just lines
I don't accept that it's just it's all
some lies that's why you make a word is
that why your books haven't sold yeah
crime huge problem what could be done
well Simple Solution guns
there's no knife crime in America is
that
in America the people most likely to own
guns are poor uneducated white men or as
I like to call them the police
15 billion bullets are produced every
year 15 billion that's enough to shoot
everyone on Earth twice
Piers Morgan 15 billion times
people think that there's something
going on I mean do you ever meet people
who are have an unreasonable Fascination
well I think there is no such thing as
unreasonable Fascination it's such a
wonderful concept to be fascinated one
of the key Inspirations behind this very
haircut was a gentleman I met called
rail rail runs an extraterrestrial cult
he believes that aliens
don't judge him for that
other than the worship of
extraterrestrials he's a very
down-to-earth man
he says the aliens can communicate
messages to us through our hair so I
thought take that to its natural
conclusion try and reach out to them a
little bit
it's not all one-way traffic well that's
right right I think you're doing us a
favor perhaps I might be I've not
received any signals as yet David other
than a very clear one from humans of get
your hair cut well I did think of
adopting for a while a little third
world child because that would tick all
three boxes wouldn't it you know you
think about one I wouldn't be adding to
the population problem I'd be allevia in
existing problem a young kid born
through no thought of his own into
abject poverty he would have died
without me I can literally save his life
and give him a great upbringing right
two he would be grateful wouldn't he he
wanna pay me back wouldn't he
particularly if I let him know that all
the other kids in the village they
weren't so lucky they didn't make it out
I'd tell him that early on so he really
bucked his ideas out like I'd go I go
Dundee come here yeah go and pop a shirt
on you're not in Africa now mate that's
better yeah yeah water straight out of a
tap and yes
no it's not free it's Hampstead yeah of
course it's safe safe fresh drinking
water have as much as you want have a
bucket full start with that fresh
drinking water there you go go and clean
the car go on
I say you could joke about anything but
not with anyone I think with you good
people this evening I should be fine
right
well let's see shall we
will put that to the test
having sex is like riding a bike
Michael told me when I was a kid
people say the best things in life are
free but those people have clearly never
had sex
the condom on for you
but I was asked to leave the pharmacy
my girlfriend doesn't think that her
sister is trustworthy but believe me
that girl can keep a secret
[Music]
I'm going to leave his with
one final piece of advice
and my advice says
never trust the super wretch what's the
first thing they do when they get rich
they buy a yacht
ever been there Yachts like being in a
two-star hotel in roller skates
the only reason anyone would want to own
a yacht is so that they can abduct
children
sail the men to international waters
them
and dispose of their bodies
and that's what everyone who owns a
yacht
is doing okay
is doing
I don't care who it is JK Rowling
I have to say for legal reasons that JK
Rowling is not and killing
children
in international waters
to the best of my knowledge
okay that's what's happening out there
sea levels aren't Rising
it's just the way of date
kids
the sea isn't even salty
[Applause]
do you know there are no hotels for the
super rich that was so exclusive that
when you phone down and ask for an extra
pillow that's actually a code one
it's actually a codeword for a
prostitute
imagine that your phone down you ask for
an extra pillow
The Prostitute turns up
now you have two prostitutes
and only one pillow to smother them with
in the middle of the night
can't go out see this is what I mean
with you you think you know it all just
go out yeah I'll tell you what then
let's go back and let's see you go out
in the middle of the night in the jungle
there's all sorts out there the noises
that's in the jungle is nothing goes to
bed at night that's why there's a lot of
nocturnal stuff no one can get their
eyes shut everything's off
African snakes going stuff flip there
was something outside the tent I'm not
joking it was Man's eyes and it was
making a human noise
was it a human no no I'm talking like
gorilla type noise right well that's
terrifying and you're saying hello but
he could go in the tent if he wanted
couldn't he no what is it what a thin
sheet of nylon keeps him all right Lads
don't go in there I don't know there's a
bit of cloth there's a bit of cloth we
can't get through that wait till he
comes out for a piss he's got an avian
bottle we're screwed I'm just saying
I had to enter the Evian bottle in the
morning no in the night because it's
only a little one so you pissed in the
tent and then emptied it out so you went
we're out there anyway yeah but it's
just me I'm going out
going like that and going back in again
surely you'd rather lose your penis than
your hand no one no nothing wants your
penis you'll be surprised
honestly there's some weird stuff out
there yeah you know this fish in the
Amazon that go up your knob
now everyone's saying to me you've seen
the Amazon that's amazing well how come
the stuff that lives in it doesn't want
to live in it you'd rather live in your
knob than living there live in the river
so you're telling me that I'm meant to
be lucky that's what I'm saying nowhere
safe you can never relax